a young girl who disappeared more than
two years ago in central new york has
been found alive police found paisley
schultes in this secret compartment
under the stairs in a home that they had
searched before officials say the little
girl was abducted by her biological
parents after they lost custody of her
our national correspondent rica duncan
shows us now how one detective paying
very close attention made the startling
discovery
after two years of searching detectives
finally found paisley schultes and this
home in saugertis new york huddled in a
small wet space beneath a staircase one
of my detectives was walked up and down
the steps a number of times during the
course of the search and he said it was
just something about the steps that was
off he used a flashlight and where two
of the step boards came together he
looked through the crack and he saw what
he believed was a blanket eventually
they saw a pair of little feet and when
they got more boards off they found the
little girl paisley
the girl now six years old was
discovered with her mother kimberly
cooper police believe cooper and the
girl's father kirk schultz jr kidnapped
paisley after losing custody of her in
2019
investigators had been to the home
before it belonged to the girl's
paternal grandfather but investigators
say a fresh tip led them to believe the
child was being hidden inside the
residence on monday officers arrived
with a search warrant they were adamant
with our officers that the child was not
there which led me to believe after the
fact that they had done this so many
times and gotten away with it both
biological parents along with paisley's
grandfather were arrested and are now
facing several charges including
endangering the welfare of a child
paisley is in good health and was
reunited with her older sister and legal
guardian for cbs mornings jerica duncan
new york
it's a very ugly story uh the police
also said that the little girl had not
been taught to read or write she's now
six and if you've ever had a
six-year-old you know it's not easy to
get them to do anything let alone get
under a stare and then be hammered in
quiet and then stay quiet that's that's
not a pretty picture i'm curious to know
why they lost stories of missing kids
usually don't end with them being found
she is safe and alive we're happy about
that as awesome